bonjour à toutes et à tous à l'heure de
l'urgence climatique comment continuer à
se déplacer tout en réduisant notre
emprinte carbone et la pollution qui tue
chaque année 40000 personnes en France
comment se passe-il de la bagnole qui
reste le moyen de transport préféré des
Français y compris pour des courtes
distance et jusqu'au plus haut sommet de
l'État on est attaché à la bagnole on
aime la bagnole et moi je l'adore cette
bagnole qui incarne donc le progrès la
liberté et à qui on voue un culte quasi
mystique ce doudou d'acier disons n'est
pas franchement neutre Raphael itiier
non en France le transport représente
un/3 de nos émissions de gaz à effet de
ser dont la moitié est impuable au
véhicules particulierers on en compte
presque 39 millions dans le pays un
chiffre en constante augmentation depuis
des décennies aujourd'hui 98 % du parc
automobile roule au diesel ou à
l'essence et seulement 1,5 % à
l'électricité exclusivement alors revoir
nos mobilités est donc une nécessité
mais suffit-il de le dire pour le faire
est vraiment à la portée de tous ceux
qui ont besoin de leur voiture pour
aller travailler et sommes-nous tous
garés sous la même enseigne selon que
l'on vit en ville ou à la campagne
quelles sont les alternatives et
sont-elles toutes à la portée de main ou
de portefeuille en attendant les ventes
de SUV explose en France au point que
l'on peut se demander si l'on ne roule
pas à contesens de l'histoire au fait
maman j'ai arrêté
l'avion
[Musique]
pour en parler la députée européenne
d'Europe et que le gilet vert Karima d
bonjour bonjour Marie Chéron de
l'association Transport et Environnement
France Bonjour bonjour et François
rouier porte-parole de la plateforme
automobile de France Bonjour bonjour et
bienvenue à tous les trois avant de vous
laisser la parole allons faire une halte
au salon de l'auto qui s'est tenu fin
septembre à Lyon cette grand mess
annuelle est l'occasion pour les
constructeurs d'exposer leurs nouveaux
modèles et pour les particuliers de les
essayer voir plus si affinités l'édition
2023 a mis la gomme sur les véhicules
électriques et hybrides et toujours à
l'honneur les SUV qui sont désormais les
voitures les plus vendues en Europe
seulement ces quatre quat urbains sont
plus lourds donc plus énergivore donc
plus polluant à la fois champion des
ventes et des émissions de CO2 pour
résumer un paradoxe à l'air de la
sobriété le tout auose c'est un
reportage d'Alexis breton Jawar Nadi et
Joseph
Alley en banlieu lyonnaise c'est jour de
fête pour la bagnole le Salon de
l'automobile un événement qui a lieu
tous les 2 ans 76000 visiteurs et plus
de 50 marques qui viennent présenter
leur modèle parmi elles
Honda allez on y va je me présente
pierre guign je suis le directeur de la
mar pour la France et on est très
heureux d'être présent aujourd'hui la
marque japonaise premier constructeur de
moteur au monde fait ces 75 ans
d'existence et maintenant on va allumer
ce beau gâteau pour cette édition
lyonnaise la marque présente en
exclusivité trois nouveaux modèles au
public Monsieur le Directeur général
nous fait une petite visite de son
standue chez
Honda juste à côté de moi vous découvrez
le nouveau Servet tout nouveau serv on
vient à peine de le lancer c'est un
vaisseau amiral pour nous c'est le SUV
iconique ça a été un des SUV les plus
vendus au monde CRV 1 ton 9 mais c'est
pas la seule par qu'on a lancé trois
nouveaux modèles et vous avez juste
devant vous le ZrV là on est sur une
voiture qui fait 4,56 donc c'est une
voiture plus compacte ZrV 1 ton6 après
on a le HRV le HRV en SUV SUV il
vient CRV ZrV HRV donc là vous avez les
trois tailles devant vous donc un
véhicule encore un peu plus compact HRV
1 ton 4 de quoi énerver surtout les
opposants au SUV SUV ou véhicule
utilitaire sportif pour les non initiés
des véhicules plus lourds et plus
polluant au Salon de l'automobile de
Lyon ils sont partout sur tous les
stands depuis quelques années ce sont
les véhicules les plus vendus dans le
monde une mode des grosses voitures
aujourd'hui dénoncée comme la pire idée
au pire moment par
[Musique]
certains la France compte près de 39
millions de voitures en circulation un
chiffre en constante augmentation et
dans cet embouteillage de moteur et de
pot d'échappement un véhicule est en
passe de remplacer tous les autres les
SUV donc en France leur vente a été
multipliée par 7 en une décennie
seulement une mode fau 44 encouragé par
la publicité qui vendent un véhicule sûr
familial et àide de grands espaces plus
haut plus large et plus cher ils sont
aussi en moyenne 200 kg plus lourds
qu'une voiture classique ils utilisent
plus de matières premières consomme plus
et rejette en moyenne 15 % de CO2
supplémentaire voiture du futur pour les
uns catastrophe environnementale pour
les autres de visions s'opposent d'un
côté Yv Cara porte-parole de
l'association mobilité Club France
et de l'autre lou espargilière
journaliste à vert le média oui la
voiture fait toujours rêver oui la
voiture est toujours utile et oui malgré
ce que pourrai dire certains politiques
la voiture on l'aime parce que c'est la
liberté en fait on est dans un moment où
il faudrait qu'on accélère extrêmement
vite sur la réduction de nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre et là débarque
l'arme fatale le SUV le truc qui va
émettre beaucoup plus de gaz à effet de
ser que les autres voitures et qui en
fait va contrecarrer tous les efforts
qui sont fait par
ailleurs au Salon de l'automobile des
milliers de visiteurs attendent
patiemment l'ouverture des portes ils
ont hâte d'admirer les nouveaux modèles
mais aussi de les essayer comme Dragan
qui est lui venu pour acheter une
voiture pas conducteur
ok je sais comment
s'ouvre accompagné d'un moniteur de la
marque Honda il va prendre le volant de
ce SV on y va donc on a aussi les
caméras qui s'allument pour les angles
morts sur l'écran quand vous mettez
j'adore il a également le fait que c'est
une voiture
neuve voit neuve c'est un plaisir de
conduire l' de 4 M70 et pesant un peu
moins de 2 tonnes ce SUV hybride est le
plus gros de la gamme Honda un gabarit
qui peut poser des problème de
conduite
attentionz
[Musique]
costaud
suspension
là c'est pas top al on peut le changer
ouais j'adore vraiment c'est absolument
ce que je rechercher au niveau du
gabarit une fois qu'on y a goûtéant
d'avoir les les véhicules surlev on a du
mal à revenir au véhicules conventionnel
je suis bien partant pour pour celui-l
parfois il y a des critiques qui sont
adressé au SUV et ce que vous en pensez
vous
[Rires]
question piège on m'avait pas prévenu
pour cette question
euh sur les véhicules ils ont raison sur
tous les véhicules
GK on
peut les écologistes ont raison mais il
va quand même acheter ce monstre de T et
d'acier en France 46 % des nouvelles
immatriculations sont des SUV devenu en
quelques années les voitures les plus
populaires les voitures ont pris du
poids les voitures ont pris de la taille
on a mis un un mot dessus SUV mais je
crois que c'est une erreur marketing si
on avait mis voiture familial ça
passerait mieux appelez le monospace il
y aura plus de problème en comptant la
fabrication et le roulage des suuv dans
le monde tout ça aimet quasiment 1
milliard de tonnes de CO2 et pour se
donner un peu un ordre d'idée c'est ce
quiim le Japon en un an où la France et
l'Allemagne réunit donc voilà en gros si
les suuv était un pays appelons-le le
suvland ce serait le 6e pays le plus
émetteur de gaz à effet sur terre des
chiffres à faire frémir n'importe quel
habitant un peu sensé de la planète et
les écologistes aussi évidemment à
l'entrée du salon Clément drognard
porte-parole d'alternatiba tente avec
ses camarades d'alerter le public
bonjour bonjour Est-ce que vous vouz une
petite fich info sur les SUV non merci
non pas de souci il y a pas de souci on
a fer une petite fiche d'information sur
les SUV si ça vous intéresse non fait un
peu de communication sur qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'un SUV pour un peu
contrebalancer le message publicitaire
ok des constructeurs ça vous parle
monsieur c'est suivez oui oui ça parle
vous en avez un oui oui écoutez n est
pascolo ça nous écoutez il y a pas de il
y a pas de souci il y a pas de
souci pas facile de convaincre ces
passionnés
d'automobile c'est vraiment pour
contrebalancer cette omniprésence
médiatique de la publicité pour les
véhicules lourds donc l'année dernière
on a eu des constructeurs qui ont
dépensé à peu près 2 milliards d'euros
dans des pour les SUV bon en fait c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu' qu' faut
qu'on arrête dernière tentative avec ses
étudiants en école d'ingénieur ce sera
encore pire on a des informations sur
les véhicules lourds la mode des
véhicules lourds si ça vous
intéresse tant qu' un GR1 nous nous on s
rien à faire la consommation c'est
vraira
ouais toutes les questions écologiques
autour de l'automobile perso moi je m'en
fous pas très écologiste non plus
j'avoue j'aime bien quand ça fait du
bruit aussi mais je pense c'est bien si
on peut trouver des alternatives qui
garde tout ce qui fait du bruit mais qui
permet de moins polluer comme ça au
moins ça PLT à tout le monde bah les SUV
ouais c'est une aberration en soi mais
ça après les gens ils recherchent de la
sécurité aujourd'hui donc faut faut les
comprendre aussi ça ça fait plaisir
petite Mustang là voilà ça fait plaisir
is est bon je vais y aller bonne journée
avec de tels ingénieurs la planète est
sans doute mal barrée aujourd'hui il y a
une voiture sur deux est vendue c'est un
SUV donc c'est une voiture normale faut
pas oublier que depuis 20 ans
l'automobile est tant mieux a fait des
efforts considérables en matière
pollution des filtres à particules pour
les les diesel beaucoup moins de
consommation pour des trajets de 1 km ou
moins réalisable en 12 minutes à pied
les gens vont prendre la voiture à 50 %
donc en fait on est dans une culture de
la voiture où la voiture est plébicitée
pour quasiment tous les trajets même les
trajets les plus courts parce que c'est
le mode de transport le plus commode
aujourd'hui pour une partie immense de
la population française une culture de
la voiture qui devient une culture du
SUV et pas seulement en France
aujourd'hui en Europe plus d'une voiture
vendue sur deux est un SUV mais au lieu
de freiner la tendance l'industrie a
trouvé la solution pour en vendre encore
plus le SUV électrique Marie Baner est
la directrice du salon de Lyon depuis
2015 moi je l'aime bien la
208 son rôle faire venir les marques et
s'assurer que ses clients sont
satisfaits
ça tu vas bien les commandes là ça se
passe bien le rythme r commandes on est
dans on est dans un avancement qui nous
va bien Renault mou représente le groupe
stellantis qui détient notamment les
marques Peugeot ou Citroën il propose
plusieurs modèles de SUV électrique il y
a un mouvement très fort sur
l'électrification ça il est clair et
vous le voyez ici on a des concurrents
que je vois ne présenter que des
véhicules électriques en 2019 sur le
marché français la part de véhiculle
électrique et hybride rechargeable
c'était de 2 % et fin août 2023 c'est de
24% en tout cas il se vend voitures sur
10 en hybride donc on peut rouler 30 à
40 % de son trajet en électrique en
ville ce qui est pas mal et le reste du
temps en thermique donc c'est écologique
c'est économique un peu moins à l'achat
mais en tout cas c'est très pratique un
SUV électrique il est beaucoup plus
lourd qu'un SUV thermique sur toute sa
durée de vie il va émettre beaucoup
moins de gaz à effet de ser qu'un
véhicule thermique en revanche comme une
grande partie de la pollution en ville
est d aux particules fines issu du
roulage et du freinage plus le véhicule
est lourd plus il va émettre ses
particules fines et donc on ne règle pas
le sujet de la pollution de l'air en
ville
sans compter la pollution engendrée par
la fabrication des batteries électriques
mais alors pourquoi achète-on autant de
SUV c'est peut-être parce que nous
sommes constamment incités à le faire
c'est ce que pens ine et Tom de militant
d'extinction rébellion je trouve que
c'est un peu mensongé quand même le
Salon de l'automobile où sont les
voitures là moi je ne vois que des
minibus en fait j'ai l'IM qu' a plus un
seul constructeur automobile qui pas de
SUV la TA de la jeep làbas aussi les de
jeunes écologistes sontitués action coup
de point mais pas cette
fois l'année dernière 11 de leurs
camarades s'étaient collé les mains à
des Ferrari au Mondial de l'OTO à
Paris une action pour laquelle il devait
être jugé en octobre dernier
ine et Tom ne souhaitent pas leur porter
préjudice avant le
procès on peut ouvrir le coffre ou
pas oh mon pote ouais en fait c'est
ça c'est petit salon ici moi j'ai des
amis qui vivent dans des voitures plus
petites que ça même s'il garde le
sourire il n'oublie pas l'essentiel leur
combat contre les SUV et leur cheval de
tro la publicité c'est la pub qui joue
énormément en fait dans le truc de de
vendre une image de quelque chose de de
de très très désirable il y a quand même
un imaginaire qui est développé de en
fait je suis tout seu sur ma sur ma
route on voit jamais un suivé dans des
bouchons ou en train de galérer dans une
ville quoi c'est genre dans des espèces
de grandes autoroutes en laass je sais
pas où il les trouve d'ailleurs
effectivement dans leur publicité voici
ce que nous montrent les grandes marques
de magnifiques routes sans la moindre
circulation dans des décors de rêve qui
nous parlent d'aventure avec des slogans
qui se veulent percutants nous les
humains ne sommes pas les animaux les
mieux
équipés pas de
fourrure pas de Griff mais des
SUV
[Musique]
alors que la réalité c'est ça ça change
tout n'est-ce pas on constate bien les
SUV en ville c'est coincé dans les
bouchons ça cllaxonne ça dépasse des
places de stationnement ce qu'il faut
être capable de faire c'est de combattre
le green washing qui a dans la publicité
parce que beaucoup d' SUV nous sont
vendus comme écolo parce qu'ils sont
hybrides alors qu'en fait ils ont un
impact climatique qui est déplorable et
il faut je sais pas moi investir
l'imaginaire dans le cinéma moi je rêve
d'une course poursuite dans un James
Bond où il serait là avec un vélo
électrique au lieu de faire une course
avec une grosse bagnole et tout le monde
trouverait ça méga classe quoi voilà il
faut ringardiser les SUV pas parce que
les SUV c'est mauvais en soi mais parce
que c'est un grave problème pour le
climat aujourd'hui en France certaines
municipalités ont décidé de ne pas
attendre les blockbuster écolo pour agir
c'est le cas de la ville de Lyon la
mairie dirigée par les écologistes
souhaite réduire la place de ses
véhicules polluant dans ses rues en
s'attaquant au
stationnement Valentin lugenstra est
adjoint au maire en charge des
transports il nous explique son projet
on aura une tarification progressive du
stationnement en fait avec trois
catégories où en fonction du poids et de
la motorisation du véhicule on sera dans
ces différentes catégories concrètement
plus la voiture est lourde et polluante
plus le tarif est élevé de 15 € par mois
pour les petites citadines jusqu'à 45 €
pour les gros SUV les grands véhicules
ont un impact sur l'espace public sur la
pollution de l'air sur le changement
climatique sur la sécurité routière sur
les métaux tout Simp simplement qui sont
utilisés qui sont un impact trop
important et il y a un certain nombre de
personnes qui ont besoin de se déplacer
en voiture il y a pas de souci mais il
vaut mieux se déplacer avec un véhicule
qui fait 1000 kg et qui prend un espace
réduit effectivement dans l'espace
public c'est tout sauf la liberté la
bagnole faut quand même savoir que en
France en moyenne chaque mois un
véhicule ça coûte plusieurs centaines
d'euros c'est entre 4 et 500 € par mois
donc en fait c'est extrêmement cher et
le fait de permettre au g de se libérer
de la voiture individuelle c'est aussi
une manière de leur redonner du pouvoir
d'achat et ça c'est un discours qu' faut
qui doit devenir enant dans l'oreille de
pas mal de gens et qu' est pas
aujourd'hui la voiture elle fera
toujours partie de notre quotidien
quelle voiture on aura quelle énergie on
aura quelle taille elle aura je ne sais
pas mais elle fera toujours partie de
notre quotidien dans les dizaines
d'années qui viennent pour le pire ou le
meilleur alors pour le pire ou le
meilleur François Rud on a bien compris
on est en pleine s Mania est-ce qu'elle
est compatible avec les objectifs
climatiques de la France à l'horizon
2035 question simple mais si cette
voiture devient ce qu'on est en train
d'en faire c'estàdire si elle est
électrique oui parce que c'est une VO
voiture qui bah selon ce qui a été
décidé en Europe va émettre zéro CO2 à
l'échappement donc c'est pas tout ce
qu'il faut faire il y a d'autres choses
à faire hein c'est ce qu'on a lancé nous
dans l'industrie c'est bah le le coût
global en CO2 de toute la fabrication de
toutes les pièces de la voiture et vous
savez qu'on est aussi sur une vision un
peu différente des véhicules qui sont
importés de Chine parce qu'un véhicule
importé de Chine bah il pose du un gros
problème en CO2 et pour répondre à votre
question on peut pas répondre tout de
suite oui ou non avant de parler de
l'électrique comment expliquez-vous que
plus les normes environnementales se
durcissent plus les suuvés sont
plébisités sachant que ces mastodontes
on l'a entendu rejettent selon les
modèle entre 11 et 26 % ce qui est
énorme de dioxyde de carbone et qu'ils
sont la deuxème source de croissance des
émissions de CO2 en France juste
derrière l'aérien alors attention à
l'appellation SUV parce que SUV c'est
devenu appellation commerciale vous avez
des petites voitures Ben qui ma fois
ressemblaient à des SUV et qu'on
appelait pas SUV une 205 ou R5 notre
jeunesse ça avait le look d'un SUV
encore une fois c'est l'appellation su
cétait c'était carréé tout petit on
appelit ça même le 44 les fameux 4 les
mini 44 aujourd'hui il faut appeler un
chat à chat un SUV est un SUV
aujourd'hui mais le problème c'est le
poid c'est pas le fait de la su CR l'un
des critères vous savez aussi bien que
moi c'est la question notamment du du
poids et à partir du poids on commence à
dessiner quoi notamment le type de
véhicule depuis 10 ans nos voitures
prennent 1 cm tous les 2 ans et 10 kg
par an pardon concrètement est-ce que
vous trouvez que l'offre des
constructeurs est alignée aux objectifs
climatiques de la France tout simplement
ça c'est une réalité c'est des faits oui
tout à fait mais lorsquon a 1 C les on a
vu une industrie automobile qui a été
dirigée par l'industrie allemande c'est
c'est simple on le sait l'industrie
allemande elle a elle a créé la voiture
telle qu'on la voit maintenant dans nos
rues alors tout le monde pour vendre ses
voitures a été obligé de plus ou moins
copier les voitures allemandes même les
Chinois he VO la marche constructeur je
crois est un peu indexée au poids aussi
donc du coup un fabricant de voiture a
tout intérêt à vendre une grosse voiture
plutôt qu'une petite salété sauf que si
vous avez une voiture thermique qui va
être très lourde vous allez avoir des
malus hein c'est chose qu'on connaît
bien en France donc on a intérêt au
contraire à diminuer le poids et vous
avez des les efforts qui sont faits sur
tous les véhicules alors que ce soit les
véhicules français ou ou étrangers de de
changement complet de conception hein on
a par exemple un châssis qui est plus
boulonné mais qui va être couler d'une
seule fois pour économiser sur ce ce
coup-là on bloque encore sur le problème
des batteries c'est sûr gros problème un
tarif de stationnement différencié selon
le poids du véhicule comme les villes de
Lyon et de Paris s prête à le faire
c'est un un bon début Marie Cheron bah
oui parce que ça donne un signal
pollueur payueur je dans dans le
principe euh c'est ça c'est-à-dire qu'on
est on est dans des villes où on a un
espace limité donc il est tout à fait
normal que le paiement du stationnement
se fasse au regard de l'espace qu'on
utilise oui ça pourrait freiner cette
estuisation galopante c'est un des
signaux mais c'est pas ça peut pas
fonctionner tout seul non plus et puis
de toute façon après quand on est en
ville le vrai enjeu des villes c'est euh
de réduire la place de la voiture pour
et de donner une vraie place aux
alternativ et cetera donc Lyon est pas
du tout en retard par rapport à ça mais
on a besoin d'avoir une dynamique
générale beaucoup plus importante
là-dessus pour qu'on puisse se déplacer
autrement et que la VO la voiture va
garder une place c'est là où je suis
assez d'accord avec ce qui dit parfois
dans dans dans le reportage c'est oui de
toute façon on va pas s'en débarrasser
de la voiture euh et peut-être que des
SUV B on va en garder en fait la
problématique derrière c'est qu'on a
aujourd'hui sur le marché il y a plus
que des SUV et il y a plus de petit
modèle direz-vous que les constructeurs
automobilees ont une part de
responsabilité en privilégiant des
voitures plus lourdes plus polluantes
inadaptées à la vie urbaine et
accessoirement plus cher aussi de 8 à 30
% euh à moteur équivalent à l'heure des
in à la sobriété bien sûr qu'ils ont une
responsabilité c'est des choix qui ont
été faits des choix stratégiques de
privilégier la rentabilité des modèles
au détriment ben de l'espace de la
transition écologique de la réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
de la réduction des émissions de
polluant atmosphérique donc oui oui ils
ont effectivement une responsabilité et
quand on regarde la façon dont est menée
la conversion vers l'électrique
aujourd'hui les SUV sont majoritairement
électriques parce que les constructeurs
européens ont choisi de rentrer dans
l'électrique par des gammes euh élevé
c'est aussi pour ça que le le manque de
petits modèles accessible et euh et peu
émetteur et plus sobre et criant il y en
a pas assez et ça permet solite en
passant d'accéder aux subventions aussi
euh quand même un SUV lourd qui est
électrifié jusqu'en 2025 je crois
bénéficie des des aides à l'achat donc
ça Perm artifici a des stratégies mais
par contre là où je rejoins monsieur
rouier c'est je pense en effet enfin
c'est tout tous les signaux qu'on a son
sont ceuxl c'est qu'il y a vraiment eu
cette augmentation du poids tirer avec
des stratégies très gros véhicules et
cetera et qu'on est un peu sur un
plateau alors àoir il va falloir que ça
se confirme parce que les alertes qu'on
lance depuis des années sur le fait que
les véhicules sont trop lourds trop gros
trop consommateur de de matière et
d'énergie bah ce heurte de plein fouet a
la nécessité dans les années à venir
d'économiser l'énergie donc de pas avoir
des véhicules qui qui consomment trop
donc on va aller chercher effectivement
les constructeurs vont chercher un peu
plus d'aérodynamisme par exemple donc on
est peut-être sur un plateau dans cette
tendance à suiv il faudrait instaurer
des malus poid absolument et je trouve
que la convention citoyenne qui avait
commencé justement à mettre le devant de
la scène des des belles propositions
malheureusement ça été des trigoté parce
queil propose c'est pire que ça c'est
que la puissance publique ne veut pas
réglementer donc nous on le fait au
niveau européen on on est quand même
dans un objectif de de plus de normes
non pas pour embêter les gens mais c'est
parce que vous l'avez dit et c'est le
cadre de votre émission nous avons une
urgence climatique c'est les SUV qui
font repartir à la hausse notamment nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ce qui
est pas normal rien que lesiv
aujourd'hui c'est un 6e pays émetteur de
gaz à effet de ser c'est 1 milliard de
tonnes de CO2 donc c'est énorme et
ensuite je voudrais revenir sur une
chose alors moi je je je pense qu'on on
ne dit pas assez la
dangerosité quand vous avez des
véhicules qui sont sur nos routes qui
pèsent plus de
1,8 bah 1,3 tonnes ou plus c'est très
dangereux la collision avec justement ce
type de de véhicule c'est deux fois plus
mortel et là on va avoir un problème
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
trajectoire qui n'est pas du tout la
bonne notamment dans les transports
c'est la raison pour laquelle il va
falloir légiférer donc c'est pas
seulement et je suis d'accord avec la
volonté de dire il faut une taxe
notamment sur les stationnements et
cetera ça c'est bien mais c'est comment
on crée les alternative et c'est là où
ça devient important dans les villes
c'est les transports en commun c'est
plus de vélo les autres en attendant le
nouveau crédau de l'industrie deobile
semble être produire moins mais vendre
plus cher or la pollution des voitures
est indexcé leur taille on l'a dit et
plus elle est importante plus les
émissions Le sont or le problème ne
vient pas des moteurs paraît-il mais des
freins et de l'abrasion c'est exact pas
pas seulement du du moteur effectivement
si on parle de de pollution au
microparticules c'est d'ailleurs un
secteur qui est un peu passé qui est un
peu dans l'angle mort de la
réglementation pendant pendant longtemps
c'estàdire que les freins quand ça
frotte ça crée des des petites
particules et les pneus en contact avec
le bitune ça met aussi des particules en
suspension on sait que c'est toxique on
sait que ce type de pollution est
responsable de de de plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de morts en France alors pas
uniquement les voitures hein mais mais
ça ça ça joue un rôle important et là on
est en train de se rendre compte de
l'ampleur du phénomène c'est que
indépendamment effectivement de la
combustion et du moteur les particules
fines issues de ces types de types de
frottement représentent plus de la
moitié de cette pollution locale et par
ailleurs je je je je lisais que sur les
les plusieurs millions de tonnes de
microplastiques qui sont rejetés dans
les océans chaque année il y en a plus
de 25 % qui viendrai des pneus donc on a
vraiment une pollution majeure qui est
pas directement lié à la question
climatique mais qui est liée à la
question environnementale évidemment
alors justement puisque l'on parle de
nuisance l'Union européenne a refusé de
durcir les normes de pollution sur les
gaz d'échappement des voitures
particulières afin de préserver la
compétitivité de l'industrie automobile
et de ces 14 millions d'emplois en
Europe elle fait bien caremadelli à
l'heure où la pollution de l'air tue de
plus en plus selon les selon les
estimations entre 40000 et 100000 décès
par an en France oui alors il ne fait
pas bien et moi je suis en colère je dis
que c'est un véritable scandale parce
qu'aujourd'hui en fait on a une norme
Euro 7 qui ressemble à la norme Euro 6
donc au fait on n pas bougé le truc
pourquoi parce que les constructeurs
automobiles disent si on met les
véhicules thermiques aujourd'hui sur la
norme r 7 ça va nous coûter 150 200 €
mais en fait ça coûte pas énormément si
vous refaites faire le vernis de votre
voiture c'est 550 € donc vous voyez donc
là c'est c'est une véritable question de
santé publique et moi je pensais que
justement le fait qu'on va sortir de la
vente des véhicules thermiques en 2035
si j'achète un véhicule thermique en
2034 il va rouler encore 15 ans 20 ans
donc c'est là qu'il faut mettre en place
la norme Euro 7 et V latip que les
constructeurs automobiles comme on dit
chez moi excusez-moi mais ils ont fait
un lobby d'enfer sur toujours la même
chose c'est-à-dire un le manque de
compétitivité de menaceant l'emploi
alors que non il y a pas de menace à
l'emploi 3 la volonté de dire attendez
on est un peu leader sur le marché on va
pas revenir à l'arrière puisque nous
notre trajectoire c'est faire plus plus
plus notamment de l'électrique je le dis
tout de suite tout le monde ne roulera
pas à l'électrique franud je pense que
ça il en l'occurrence le lobby d'enfer
le lobby d'enf ça vous
concerne le lobby d'en mais non mais
c'est simple nous c'est une réaction
tout à fait simple industrielle
commerciale on arrête les voitures THM
non pas en 2035 mais en 2030 chez
stantis c'est fini en 2030 donc on va
pas dépenser de l'argent pour la la fin
de porter et qu'est-ce que vous faites
des véhicules qui vont être achetés
avant en 2029 ils vont rouler jusqu' rou
jus publicité un peu partout on essaie
de vendre des voitures publicit
électriqu voilà il y a plus que des
publicités sur les voitures électriques
et de toute façon vous avez d le voir
même dans les nouveaux modèles avant on
sortait un modèle thermique et puis on
disait il y a aussi des versions
électriques oui mais ça c'est pas juste
ce que vous faites parce que vous êtes
en de prendre en otage la santé des gens
vous savez très bien que tout le
mond voitur qui sont vendu dépend du
parc
automob supr le
par franis rier à Paris à Paris on
commence à à Paris on commence à
dépolluer l'air dans les cours d'école
avec des purificateurs d'air géant c'est
le CASAM de l'école victoire é
ondissement que l'on en soit réduit à
capter les particules fines pour ramener
la pollution de l'air au-dessous des
seuils fixés par l'EMS vous trouvez ça
normal mais non mais vous avez vu ce qui
roule à Paris vous avez vu ce qui roule
à Paris que ce soit en voiture
particulière ou pire en camionnette non
mais c'est délirant c'est on est
quasiment dans les années 70 maintenant
sur les trucs là et c'est ça le problème
le problème c'est le parc automobile et
là on a besoin des politiques pour
sortir ces véhic ils l'ont dit il y a 31
million de de voitures avec les les VUL
qui les véhicules utilitaires légers qui
circulent je vous parle pas des camions
he les camions de 3 tonnes5 qui viennent
de polne ou lit faire des véhicules
électriques Monsieur R croyez vous appuz
sur un bouton on va avoir 31 million de
véhicul électriqu on peut déjà rajunir
le parc quid à présent de cette voiture
électrique dont on nous vente les
mérites pour la rendre accessible à tous
le gouvernement a reéhaussé le bonus
écologique pour les ménages les plus mod
de 6 à 7000 € selon les critères de
poids et de prix du véhicule la liste
des modèles subventionnés sera connue je
crois en décembre mais ces autos sont
pourtant loin d'être la panacée écolore
fétiier c'est l'heure de votre
[Musique]
climatoscope alors la voiture électrique
n'est pas la panacée effectivement
néanmoins il n'y a pas de doute sur le
fait qu'un véhicule électrique a un
impact carbone moindre qu'un V
Therm c'estd on estime si on prend tout
tout en compte le cycle de vie que
qu'une voiture électrique a un impact de
à TR fois inférieur à celui d'une
voiture thermique en moyenne donc au
regard du climat la voiture électrique
c'est mieux qu'une voiture thermique ça
c'est acquis et on peut maintenant
discuter de l'intérêt de la voiture éri
pouro aant de critiqueors par parce que
ce qui est vrai aussi c'est que le bilan
carbone de la voiture électrique à la
fabrication est beaucoup moins favorable
parce qu'il faut fabriquer la carcasse
il faut fabriquer le moteur et il faut
fabriquer en plus la batterie qui est
très coûteuse en énergie et qui en plus
nécessite d'aller chercher du lithium
notamment dont l'extraction
est plutôt est plutôt coûteuse donc au
départ ça c'est plutôt un désavantage
environnemental mais comme on ne brûle
pas d'essence à son utilisation on
rattrape en fait ce ce ce ce ce bilan
carbone et on estime qu'en France en
moyenne au bout de 50000 km le bilan
carbone devient favorable pour le
véhicule électrique en France mais qu
des des des centrales qui roulent au
charbon effectivement alors en France on
a une électricité plutôt décarbonée en
Pologne c'est un peu moins le cas la
Chine c'est encore moins le cas il
n'empêche que au bout du compte à la fin
de vie du véhicule on est quand même sur
un bilan CO2 qui est favorable ça prend
plus de temps parce que le coût initial
est plus important mais à la fin on y
est quand même alors maintenant si on
roule en véhicule électrique est-ce que
on est euh on est sur un versant
purement écologique non parce qu'il y a
un autre paramètre qui est très
important important c'est le poids du
véhicule on en discutait tout à l'heure
le le le le problème c'est que le SUV
même électrique reste une une
aberération car la puissance de la
batterie qui est indexée sur le poids du
véhicule bah gros véhicule grosse
batterie gros impact écologique et il
est beaucoup plus difficile de compenser
les les émissions de de de de gaz à
effet de serre lié à sa production donc
avec une voiture électrique et légère on
n'est pas certain d'être absolument
écolo non non non et on a encore pas
fait le le le le le on n'est pas encore
arrivé à destination quand on on a une
voiture légère et électrique parce que
si on passe de je suis tout seul dans ma
voiture thermique à je suis tout seul
dans ma voiture
électrique on ne rentre pas dans le
cadre des accords de Paris c'està-dire
que la neutralité carbone va imposer une
réduction du nombre de véhicules au
niveau au niveau du parc ce qui veut
dire bah du partage du covoiturage et
augmenter les transports en commun pour
permettre aux gens de se passer de la
voiture aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu
compliqué en terme d'urbanisation et
tout ça mais on ne si on veut que le
trans transport rentre dans les accords
de Paris il va falloir agir sur ces
trois TR trois facteurs il faut rentrer
dans l'électrique il faut alléger les
véhicules et il faut faire d'autres
propositions de transport ou alors un
mot des batteries si si les voitures
électriques restent tel quell c'est des
SUV à grosse batterie les matières
première vont nécessairement commencer à
manquer pour répondre à la demande
croissante d'ici 2035
l'approvisionnement en lithium
risquet-il d'être un autre problème à
nicherou alors il y a pas de problème de
réserve de ressources disponibles la la
difficulté c'est que c'est le temps
nécessaire pour mettre en place ouvrir
les mines et cetera et répondre à la
demande donc c'est tout ce travail
d'exploitation et de mise sur le marché
des des produits c'est un coût
écologique l'extraction du lithium a un
coût écologique exactement d'êre surtout
que l'Europe c'est défait de toutes ces
activités minières depuis plusieurs
décennies préér mettre un peu plus loin
donc il y a un vrai enjeu aujourd'hui
avec certains projets miniers en Europe
justement l'Union européenne souite
relocaliser fabrication des batteries
mais il y a beaucoup de de gens qui ne
veulent pas de ça ne veulent pas de de
gisement d'exploitation de mine beaup
gens qui n'en veulent pas mais d'un
point de vue écologique le mal il est
aussi important que ce soit l'autre bout
de la planète ou chez nous donc la voir
chez nous c'est aussi se mettre face à
l'impact de nos consommations et c'est
d'assumer et donc sans doute ben oui de
pousser vers la sobriété et vers
des il y a aussi un gros enjeu à avoir
des mines qui soient beaucoup plus des
activités minres qui soient beaucoup
plus responsables et dans la dans la
responsabilité il y a aussi limité et
maîtriser la consommation qui va être
extraite et derrière l'autre gros enjeu
c'est d'aller d'aller mettre en place
dès aujourd'hui les activités de
recyclage qui vont permettre d'ici 10 ou
15 ans quand le stock de batterie sera
de batterie en fin de vie sera sera
suffisant de pouvoir les recycler et de
les réutiliser et donc là-dessus on a
quand même une directive enfin un
règlement batterie au niveau européen
qui fixe des objectifs de réutilisation
de de de métaux recyclés donc ça c'est
quand même important c'est vrai qu'on a
c'est c'est 10 15 ans qui sont
difficiles mais il y a un vrai débat en
France sur-ce qu' justement que dire aux
populations local qui voit d'un très
mauvais œil une l'ouverture d'une mine
près de chez eux on l'a vu à échassière
dans l'allié mais aussi à desbrchenen en
Hongrie ou à losnica en Serbie où les
riverins se mobilisent contre
l'ouverture d'une usine de batterie ou
l'exploitation d'ingisement de lithium
bref ils refusent de sacrifier leur
région au nom de la transition
énergétique européenne que faut-il leur
dire bah il faut il faut analyser les
projets voir s'ils sont vraiment
implantés au bon endroit c'est plus
intéressant de le faire sur des sur des
sites qui ont déjà été des des endroits
où il y avait une exploitation minière
que dans des nouveaux sites comm cas
ouais et puis comme c'est le cas en serv
en Serbie ou au Portugal où on a des
sites qui sont aujourd'hui des des des
espaces agricoles avec des petites
exploitation et on vient proposer un
projet de mine là ça peut effectivement
enfin ça pose de fait des problèmes et
dans les sites qui avaient été repérés
en France puisque au au départ il y
avait il y a plusieurs sites qui ont été
explorés et finalement celui qui est
retenu est un site en enciennement déjà
industrialisé donc oui il faut faire des
choix raisonnés donc je crois que ça ça
va être essentiel et après il y a les
questions liées à à la ressource en eau
et cetera donc là la responsabilité faut
être absolument très stricte sur la
responsabilité environnemental on a
parlé de l'électrique un mot des
voitures à hydrogène peut-être c'est un
miroir aux alouettes pour l'instant
c'est une des solutions mais à grand
gabarit sur des grands volumes de de
véhicules je vous le dis ça va pas être
possible aujourd'hui pour les flottes
Toyota Françis il croit dur comme faire
mais en tout cas pour l'instant c'est
pas la panassée moi je voudrais revenir
sur ce que dit Marie chon parce que
lorsqu'on a des vision par exemple sur
des mix énergétiques totalement nouveaux
et cetera c'est que l'industrie
automobile va devoir réfléchir sur de la
prospective de filière et là on a un
problème parce que on doit pas juste
penser la batterie on doit penser
l'ensemble notamment du véhicule et la
filière c'est la seconde vie c'est
comment on recycle l'ensemble des
matériaux et cetera et il y a un marché
par contre sur lequel moi je trouve
qu'on réfléchit pas assez c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'industrie du rétrofit
qu'est-ce que c'est messieurs dames oui
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est très simple
vous avez une un véhicule thermique en
fait on change le moteur pour faire un
véhicule électrique et ça c'est c'est
quand même dingue parce qu'on a les
meilleurs réofiturs en Europe vous êtes
d'accord Françis Rud bah oui Renault le
fait mais le problème c'est le coût
c'est le coût et après c'est la sécurité
du véhicule qui a été fait il y a
quelques années puisqu'il a rétrofité
avec un une batterie qui est plus lourde
un freinage différent pour tout quand
essay des voitures électriqu vous avez
vu ça a pas du tout le même comportement
hein un moteur thermique ça ça ça monte
en puissance un moteur électrique c'est
tout de suite la puissance donc c'est
dangereux donc ça veut dire que bah ça
rajoute des contraintes au rétrophit
donc ça rajoute du coup mais sur le
rétropit mais c'est super d'avoir les
des maris par exemple électrique ça
marche très bien euh bon il y a il y a
un côté ludique sur certaines choses qui
peut se faire sans problème il peut y
avoir aussi des des rétropites de camion
et de camionnett ça c'est pas idiot
parce que ça peut euh plus pertinent sur
les camionnettes que sur les voitures
individu parce qu'en fait c'est sur des
usages qui peuvent être plus courts par
exemple vous avez des l'usage de la
Poste La Poste utilise des véhicules
électriques parce que ils font des des
stop and go ils font pas finalement un
grand trajet mais vont faire du stop and
go donc c'est vous vous avez pas la même
contrainte que sur un véhicule qui va
rouler sur une route à à 90 à l'heure
j'aimerais aller très vite sur la
question des des biocarburants il en est
beaucoup question notamment du
superéthanol E85 ou des carburants de
synthèse comme le euel ils sont tous
présentés comme l'essence du futur et
pourtant très controversé ce que l'État
a raison de leur multiplier les cadeaux
fiscaux car moi je ne suis pas d'accord
sur ça parce que c'est un sparadra sur
une jambe de bois vous voyez et
lorsqu'on a négocié notamment les la fin
de la vente des véhicules thermiques au
niveau européen les Allemands sont
arrivés en disant nous on veut le
carburant de synthèse mais aujourd'hui
il y a pas beaucoup de pays qui savent
faire des carburants de synthèse et ça
il faut le dire même nous en Europe on
sait pas le faire donc je crois que
c'est pas une bonne idée et la vraie
question on en a pas du tout parlé mais
je voudrais le redire c'est que s'il
faut changer des fl flotte il faut
commencer par les camions parce que vous
et moi les gens les particul on peut
choisir l'alternative à la voiture on
peut prendre un train un bus à Métro et
ce les marchandises c'est un peu
compliqué car vous oubliez la fracture
territoriale et d'ailleurs d'ici 2025
les villes françaises de plus de 150000
habitants devront mettre en place des
zones à faible émission 43 métropoles
sont concernées mais ces restrictions de
circulation sont très fortement critiqué
elle risque effectivement de creuser un
peu plus la fracture territoriale alors
d'abord la fracture territoriale elle
existe on a dit à tout le monde ayez un
véhicule non deux véhicules soyez
notamment dans le dans le péri urbain ou
dans le rural et une belle maison et
cetera et sauf que à l'achat de deux
véhicules pour des ménages aujourd'hui
le c'est un véhicule en France c'est
5000 € donc ça fait 10000 € par an et
pas d'autre alternative d'où la question
du déis et là on peut le dire de la
puissance publique sur la question
notamment des gilets jaunes les gilets
jaune disait mais attendez c'était la
goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder le
Vince mais parce qu'il n'avait pas d'
alternative donc à votre question sur
les Z feux les zfeux vont devoir être
accompagnés par des alternatives moi je
pense que je suis fe pardon ça dire les
zones à faible émission c'est quand même
dur pour les gens de leur dire tel
véhicule vous pouvez pas passer et
cetera parce que vous avez un essiv
électrique vous passez quelqu'un qui a
pas les moyens et qui on diesel il passe
pas donc là il a il y a quelque chose d'
d'injuste en terme donc moi je dis il
faut mettre en place les AFE parce que
c'est un un moyen incroyable sur la
pollution de l'air qui est je rappelle
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est l'ONU qui
l'OMS qui dit c'est la maladie du 21e
siècle donc il faut le faire maintenant
il va falloir programmer et intensifier
notamment les alternatives difficile de
parler de mobilité sans parler de la 69
et de ces 53 km d'autoroute défendu par
la présidente d'ocitan Carole Delga pour
relier castre à Toulouse qui prévoit
d'ensevelir sous le bitum 400
h etes un tronçon trèsé est-ce que ce
projet à l'heure des injonctions à la
sobriété n'est-il pas anachronique c'est
anachronique et c'est une aberration
économique environnementale tout ce que
vous voulez en plus une autoroute où on
va faire payer 17 € voyez c'est un peu
une autoroute un peu de riche alors que
la solution là il y a une voie notamment
qu'on appelle le train donc il faut la
rénover l'électrifier et puis tout le
monde sera content Bir rier sur la 69
écoutez nous sur les autoroutes ce qu'on
voit c'est que les autoroutes ça devient
effectivement la route du riche hein on
a toutes les bornes électriques sur les
autoroutes ce qui fait que on reporte
tout le trafic des camions des 3 T5 qui
roulent le weekend parce qu'ils sont pas
interdits et qui détruisent les routes
et on a un état des routes en France
qu'ell soit même nationale ou alors pire
lorsqu'on descend qui est horrible qui
en plus maintenant arrive à la charge
des communautés de communes qui peuvent
pas les entretenir on déclasse des des
chemins en France des routes tous les
ans donc vous parlez de fracture
territoriale la mobilité en ruralité
actuellement c'est catastrophique moi je
sais j'en viens c'est dire que donc il
faudrait développer le rail comme le
ditv le rail com on dit développer le
rail ça veut dire déjà faire venir le
rail vous avez plusieurs y a beaucoup de
lignes qu'il faudrait réinvestir les
réouvrir parce que le train c'est
gagnant gagnant gagnant pour le climat
gagnant pour le pouvoir d'achat et
gagnant pour l'emploi parce qu'il va
falloir embaucher quoi mais ce que vous
disiez c'est qu'on nous a vendu un
modèle à l'américaine avec l'étalement
urbain aujourd'hui on peut plus se
passer de la bagnole comment fait-on
pour se passer la bagnole AB et ben ça
tombe bien c'est pour ça que demain la
voiture elle ne sera plus dans la
possession elle sera partagée parce que
tout le monde roule un peu tout seul
dans sa voiture et dans le péri urbain
il faut revoir les cadences le
covoiturage c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire on n même pas
réellement de de route de covoiturage ça
se fait partout en Europe sauf chez nous
et ensuite il va falloir aussi apprendre
du covid que nous a appris le covid et
ben c'est qu'on pouvait un peu aussi se
moins se déplacer faire du télétravail
et ben il y a plein de gens qui sont
dans les zones Z rurale qui veulent un
jour ou deux de de télétravail voir des
lieux qu'on appelle les tierslieux donc
des lieux intermédiaires où on puisse
aller travailler où il y a du lien
social effectivement télétravailler un
jour par semaine c'est 170000 barils en
moins 3 jours c'est 500000 barils de P
sauf qu'il faut penser à toutes les
professions qui n'ont pas le choix je
pense aux KR aux infirmières et cetera
qui n'ont pas le choix donc c'est dans
ces lieu là où on roule beau tout où il
faut mettre des bornes électriques où
c'est là où ce ser donc il faut aussi
imaginer des villes plus plus propice
aussi à la marche voilà et au vélo et au
vélo alors en attendant de façonner no
ville autrement et de laisser la reine
du bitum au garage certains se sont mis
en marche pour encourager nos enfants à
faire à pied ce qu'ils font
habituellement en voiture tout le monde
y gagne la planète les marcheurs et le
lien social qui dit mieux le monde de
demain commence aujourd'hui comme le
montre ce reportage d'éix breton et
jaoir
nadie
Mar dans le Val de Marne au petit
matin allez les
chaussettes 3 ans et dem se prépare à
aller à l'école Lorian maman ve à ce que
rien ne manque dans le cartable de son
petit
champion VO doudou
[Musique]
tout
on essaie de se préparer on est
généralement à l'avance parce qu'il se
lève très tôt fort heureusement et du
coup on les dépose on les dépose pour 8h
tu fais le bisous à ta
sœur bisous le bisous le bisous
ouais bonne
[Musique]
journée allez à tout à l'heure bisous
mimine en petite section de maternelle
Mayan se sert d'un moyen de locomotion
originale pour aller à l'école est-ce
qu'ils sont déjà arrivés tu crois on va
voir il utilise ses pieds ça n'a l'air
de rien mais un enfant qui marche
aujourd'hui c'est un adulte qui ne
prendra pas une voiture
demain bonjour an
bonjouran tu vas bien
ou bonjour ça va la chic conduit le
péibus depuis
regarde une alternative simple et
efficace à la voiture ou au car scolaire
quand on sait qu'en moyenne les enfants
habitent à moins de 2 km de leur école
et qu'un adulte sur de privilégie la
voiture pour les trajets de 1 km ou
moins et oui tu vois c'est la saison
quand même en automne les marrons
tombent on découvre les saisons et ça
c'est vraiment fabuleux donc ils
apprennent les noms des fleurs et puis
on leur apprend aussi à traverser les
rues puis les enfants sont éveillés ils
sont bien quoi puis surtout on donne un
exemple pour les autres parents pour que
les enfants marchent à pied quoi
imaginez aujourd'hui 30 % des 26
millions de trajets quotidiens pour
emmener les enfants à l'école se font en
voiture ce sont autant de trajets qui
pourrait être évité grâce à la marche et
c'est aussi un bon moyen de lutter
contre la sédentarité des enfants dont
17 % sont en surpoids en France Bonjour
Sophia bonjour
Julie ça va donc voilà la ligne de
l'arrêt de la ligne de péibus ici c'est
Batman et ça c'est les enfants qui ont
donné le nom tout au début du péibus
allez on y va cette année 24 enfants
sont inscrits à ce service
d'accompagnement gratuit assuré par des
retraités mais aussi par certains
parents comme Flavie mère de deux
petites
passagères moi les filles son sont ravis
de faire le Pédibus tous les jours ell
retrouvent les copains
B sauf quand il pleu c'est moins rigolo
ça permet d'éviter de TR du coup la
voiture tout à fait tout à fait ça c'est
vrai que c'est pratique allez Victoria
tiens donc les deux dernières là-bas
c'est mes filles bonjour Maë bonjour
Edden ça va le pédiibus c'est sympa pour
les
enfants maintenant que la voiture
s'arrête elle s'est arrêté donc on peut
passer merci et on lui dit merci
beaucoup mais ce n'est pas de tout repos
pour les
adultes Mayan voilà on se met là et on
regarde d'abord à gauche et après à
droite hein voilà en France la voiture
individuelle représente 54 % des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre du
secteur des
transports favoriser la marche notamment
pour les petits trajets serait donc très
bénéfique pour notre planète
mon bonjourour pas qui font de grandes
avancées donc c'est 25 minutes de marche
mais voyez même un petit de petite
section de maternelle peut tout à fait
faire ça et la majorité des enfants
habitent à peu près à 20 minutes donc
tout le monde pourrait venir à pied
allez on va à l'école depuis 14 ans agès
a accompagné plus de 400 enfants en
France on compte 800 lignes de pédibus
et de nouvelles sont créées chaque année
elles ouvrent tout le chemin vers un
avenir plus durable alors lespédibus ça
marche du tonneur si on additionne les
12 millions d'élèves de la maternelle au
lycée au millions d'enseignants c'est 26
millions de déplacements aller-retour
chaque jour ce n'est pas anonin en terme
d'emprinte carbone ça fait du monde
absolument ça fait beaucoup de monde le
problème que nous avons c'est de de
véritablement de se dire il faut
remarcher h là on a un problème ça veut
dire que vraiment la voiture nous a pris
énormément pas seulement de l'imaginaire
mais aussi dans nos comportements la
voiture est le moyen privilégié pour les
trajets domicile travail y compris pour
les trajets de moins de 5 km ces distan
elle pourraitre facilement être fait en
milité douce non qu'est-ce qui coince
alors moi je dirais surtout c'est
surtout en nuux sur les trajets de d'un
km attention parce que 5 km c'est
souvent 5 + 5 + 5 on va poser les
enfants on va faire des courses on va au
travail 15 km là on entre quand même
dans des dans des moments où a pas de on
prend la voiture alors c'est vrai que
les enfants qui sont emmenés en voit
à l'école écoutez pour moi qui suis un
vieillard qui est passé ma jeunesse à
pied puis après en vélo en cassant
plusieurs vélos qui devait faire 10 km
par jour aller retour et venir manger à
la maison je comprends pas je comprends
pas où est venue cette mode est-ce qu'il
y a eu une peur de sur la sécurité des
enfants c'est possible ce qui est vrai
c'est que nos territoires ont été
aménagés pour et par la voiture
aujourd'hui ou quelque chose qu'on voit
dans le reportage c'est que le trottoir
est pas très large sur quelque chose
comme ça c'est que la voiture a pris de
la place à GRG et il y a plus de place
et un parent ne laisse pas son enfant
aller à l'école tout seul s'il y a un
risque de se faire renverser donc il y a
aussi un vrai enjeu d'aménagement
d'aménagement de circuit sécurisé et
cetera donc il y a plusieurs
collectivités qui travaillent dessus
mais quand on regarde en détail les
programmes des villes bah c'est très
compliqué de remettre équip de récréer
de la signalétique des choses qui soient
sûr pour faire ralentir les voitures
pour que les enfants soient bien mais
mais concrètement comment sortir du tout
bagnool sachant que la le véhicule reste
la pierre angulaire de déplacementah ça
la reste la angulaire de nos
déplacements elle est obligatoire pour
beaucoup de gens oui surtout dans je le
répète surtout dans le pé urbain et dans
le rural dans les centre-ville
aujourd'hui on a les alternatives on a
la marche on a le vélo on a le transport
en commun et cetera le problème c'est
qu'il faut un choc d'offre notamment
d'alternative dans le milieu rural et
dans le milieu urbain par exemple il y a
pas assez notamment de fréquence de
transport public dans le rural et dans
le pé urbain comment se fait-il alors
Macron ambitionne de réduire d'ici à
2030 nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de 55 % par rapport à 1990 et il
s'est engagé à lancer 13 nouveaux
projets de RR métropolitain cararimell
alors tout d'abord les RER
métropolitains on est tous contents
c'est super il y a plus de train et
cetera sauf que il faut dire la vérité
ça veut dire que ça va prendre du temps
ça veut dire ça va prendre une dizaine
d'années donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
maintenant tout de suite il faut rénover
les lignes de T ça c'est la première
chose deuxième chose il faut plus de T
hop choc de l'offre plus de frais
séquence deuxè objectif trème objectif
c'est le matériel roulant on a pas
de bah si j'ai pas de train je peux pas
mettre des traines sur les lignes donc
il faut rénover la signalisation et il
faut lancer l'industrie du train et
c'est là où c'est extraordinaire le
fameux ticket climat et là ça revient
aussi au choc de ce qu'on dit
l'accessibilité c'est la raison pour
laquelle au niveau européen tout le
monde met en place notamment des tickets
climat ce sont des abonnements illimités
pour prendre n'importe où en France
notamment pour 49 € tous les T et tous
les transports en commun parce que le
gouvernement est malin ça a été mis en
place en Autriche en Allemagne en
Espagne et récemment quelques lignes au
Portugal sauf que le gouvernement est
malin il parle de passe rail pas de
ticket climat parce que lui il voit
juste les TER et pas les transports en
commun alors qu'il faut de
l'intermodalité les gares quand je sors
d'une gare je dois avoir un vélo un
couoiturage un bus et cetera et c'est ça
qui va faire en sorte que demain et ben
la voiture prendra de moins en moins de
place il un vrai en jeu
d'accord
Mar on va vous laisser vrai enjeu à ce
que tous les les différents modes soient
cha vous êtes d'accord Françis rouier ah
mais surinmodalité oui aussi ah bah
voilà
unanimité vous arrivez vous arrivez avec
un train euh et l'ut l'autre train la
correspondance est partie depuis 5
minutes ça c'est récurrent dans nos
gares en France c'est typique donc il y
a un vrai sujet d'intermodalité et puis
vous arrivez dans la gare il y aura pas
forcément stationnement il y aura pas
forcément le le mode adapté pour vous
rendre à destination donc là il y a un
vrai y je et là aujourd'hui c'est
largement insuffisant il y a pas de
politique majeure dessus en attendant on
le répettera jamais assez le passé est
un bon indicateur de l'avenir comme
chaque mois Charlotte ETP est allé
fouiller dans les archives de Lina et
nous a exhumé ceci hier encore c'est
notre coup d'œil dans le rétro et c'est
maintenant cette fois c'est sérieux à
partir du 1er janvier prochain la lutte
contre les fumées produites par les
véhicules va entrer dans une une phase
active regardez ces camions les
principaux fautifs à chaque fois que
leur conducteur change de vitesse c'est
un nuage noir qui se répand dans
l'atmosphère et ces fumées proviennent
le plus souvent d'un mauvais réglage du
moteur aussi l'arrêté que Monsieur Marc
Jaquet ministre des Travaux publics
vient-il de signer prescrit-il qu'aucun
véhicule ne devra désormais émettre de
fumées nettement teinté ou opaque seul
pourront être toléré des émissions
fugitive au moment des changements de
régime du moteur aussi bien les poids
lourds que les voitures particulières
qui va contrôler les services techniques
de la police à Paris par exemple la
préfecture de police dispose d'appareils
spéciaux qu'on branche sur le tube
d'échappement des véhicules et qui
mesure la quantité et la nocivité des
fumées le camion dont l'échappement est
jugé défectueux doit être réglé et
présenté à nouveau si l'amélioration
obtenue n'est pas suffisante une amende
pourra à partir du 1er janvier être
infligée au contrevenant quelques
dérogation exceptionnelle peut-être
pendant un an encore qui seront accordés
par le Service des Mines mais le combat
contre la pollution de l'air des villes
exigeait une action immédiate elle est
engagée elle est engagée caréadellie bah
elle était déjà engagée il y a quelques
années on voit avec déjà à l'époque on
calculait les particuli fes mais
aujourd'hui ça devient toujours un des
problèmes moteurs de nos sociétés c'est
le cas de le dire
moto JEE mot naturel impossible de nous
quitter sans donner la parole à notre
écho activiste préféré Camille Etienne
est de retour et elle a quelque chose à
vous dire c'est l'heure de sa carte
verte am Étienne c'est à
vous le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
que la tendance n'est pas au claquage de
portièrees l'industrie de l'auto n'a pas
prévu de rouler au pas on n jamais vendu
autant de SUV qu'aujourd'hui et même
s'il faut 10 tonnes de pétrole rien que
pour construire une voiture que c'est un
des plus gros facteurs d'émission de gaz
à effet de ser dans notre pays que les
particules fines donnent des cancers du
poumon à nos enfants leur vente explose
expose littéralement même le président
de la République il y a quelques jours
dans un de ces discours officiels et
policiers nous glissaient pourtant un
nous les français on adore la bagnole
alors j'ai repensé à tous ces souvenirs
construits dans mon technococon aux
confessions sur le volant aux copilotes
monomaniaque de Dalida aux enguelades
avec mon frère pour savoir qui montera
devant au sandwich triangle les plus
chers et les moins bons de France sur
les aires d'autoroute au jambon gourd à
la légère nausée et au retour de nuit
c'est vrai qu'on y est bien dans notre
technococon qu'on croit y être bien
quand on oublie que les paysages qui
glissent à la fenêtre disparaissent pour
de vrai à mesure des kilomètres qu'on
croit y être bien jusqu'à ce qu'on se
prenne le mur de la catastrophe
climatique en plein parbrise l'impact
sans airbag ni ceinture de sécurité vers
lequel l'industrie automobile nous
projette à vive alure alors la vraie
question est peut-être la seule qui
devrait nous obséder c'est de savoir si
la voiture roule encore pour nous ou
bien si c'est nous qui roulons pour que
son industrie continue à faire du profit
le philosophe Jacques et lul nous
alertait déjà sur le lien de domination
entre l'homme et l'outil il y a ce point
de bascule au-delà duquel le rapport
s'inverse on devient à son service plus
que l'inverse en 1973 déjà Ivan ilich
faisait le calcul un Américain moyen
consacre 1600 heur par an à sa voiture
soit 4 heur par jour il y a le temps en
voiture certes mais à celui-ci s'ajoute
le temps de travail pour la payer puis
payer l'essens les payages l'assurance
les impôts et les réparations pour tout
ce temps donné l'Américain moyen parcour
une distance de 10000 km il avance donc
à 6 km/h c'est à peine plus qu'une
marche rapide je rentre d'un weekend de
mobilisation contre l'autoroute a69
entre castre et Toulouse pour gagner 17
minutes des centaines d'arbres autant
d'hectares de terre cultivabl et des
gens expropriés de leur maison sur le
tracé entre garder des champs pour se
nourrir et agrandir les routes pour
aller plus vite au super marché ils ont
choisi dans une tribune plus de 1500
scientifiques du JC et du CNRS nous
alertaient chaque mètre carré de terre
que l'on artificialise participe à
compromettre les conditions de vie sur
Terre pourtant d'ici à 2050 il y aura
plus de 25 millions de kilomètres de
routes supplémentaires soit 600 fois le
tour de la terre on roule à plus de 110
km/h vers une 6e extinction de masse à
coup de pelleteuse nous sommes en train
de manger le monde et de couler la vis
ou du bitume pour gagner quelques
minutes de trajet ils accélèrent notre
chute alors on continuera avec
abnégation à ralentir leur monde contre
leur payage à leur faire payer
l'enlaidissement du monde qui nous
impose face à leur couloir de bitum ont
choisi des chemins de traverse face à la
honteuse direction du monde qui nous
disent inévitable on construit une autre
route venez la voieba François Rudier je
vous vois écouter ça avec beaucoup
d'attention je respecte toutes les
religions une religion mal vous n'avez
pas envie de répondre quelque chose à à
cette à ce billet de Camille c'est un
beau texte
ou on ne partage pas mal de choses oui
c'est vrai détruire des paysage c'est
une catastrophe utilisons déjà tout ce
qui a été implanté pour l'améliorer h
voilà vous allez nous aider contre la
69 avant de se quitter voici quelques
scèes recommandations de lecture pour
aller plus loin je ne veux pas vous
faire plaisir François rouer moins
d'auto pour aller au boulot de Corentin
le Martelot dans la collection je passe
à l'acte aux éditions Acte
Sud euh tout comprendre ou presque sur
le climat préfacé par Valérie maçon
d'mote au CNRS édition et chaleur
humaine de Nabil Wakim aux éditions du
Seuil 1 m voilà bonne lecture d'ici là
soyez heureux on se retrouve le mois
prochain pour vous parler du béton vaste
sujet merci à
tous
[Musique]